[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale à ryder cup au
programme aujourd'hui les deux derniers
jours de compétition vous verrez
également les à côté de cette ryder cup
[Musique]
à peine le golf national ouvert les
supporters un s'empresse d'aller à dans
l'es1 food trucks faut prendre leur
petit déjeuner essentiellement ils
peuvent manger des produits anglais
c'est un très gros événement nous
n'avions jamais fait quelque chose comme
ça avant
je pense que c'est le premier événement
de golf au monde c'est une bonne
expérience nous servons environ entre
3000 et 10000 europe 1
une fois restaurée direction les
tribunes les supporters ont mis le feu
comme le vendredi ils sont plus de
soixante mille à encourager les joueurs
sur le trou numéro un les européens
n'ont pas hésité à déstabiliser les
adversaires
[Applaudissements]
les supporters européens brûlant qui ont
permis à leurs protégés de remporter
cette journée de mener 10 à 6 à la fin
de celle ci sa thèse des jours par fait
un bel effort d'équipé très beau jeu de
l'équipe européenne
un bel esprit d équipe de thomasz byrne
et de ses joueurs nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes tous ensemble ils
s'entraident cessé qu'avec les plus
anciens aux plus jeunes nous ne faisons
qu'un mais les vingt dix supporters
américains présents golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines désespère pas
dimanche sera un grand jour c'est sûr ce
matin ça a été compliqué mais demain
sera une bonne journée et notre joueur
web va nous apporter la victoire
l'équipe américaine est toujours une
bonne équipe et j'ai toujours supporté
les américains évidemment l'équipe
européenne est forte aussi mais en tant
qu'américaine je dois supporter tiger et
ses coéquipiers comme ça
m
oh
[Musique]
s'il ya bien une équipe qui a
impressionné tout le monde ce samedi à
c'est la paire molinari fleetwood et ils
ont même battu a taillé en mousse sur
deux matches on leur a même trouvé un
solo et molly weasley words words
signifie qu'elles veulent faire un
fabuleux sweeney il joue bien avec le
mans une source d'inspiration
pas grand chose qu'on puisse ajouter à
une telle performance et une performance
absolument époustouflante
cette paire résulte de longues
conversations de réflexion avec ces deux
joueurs également la relation qu'ils ont
ensemble depuis longtemps
il avait envie de jouer ensemble notre
image du jour les supporters venus du
monde entier en portent avec eux une
histoire si fans irlandais en voulue par
exemple rendre hommage à leur père
décédé avant la ryder cup
i do it for weeks ago il est mort il ya
quatre semaines sur un parcours de golf
en irlande
il est impatient de venir ici
donc maintenant il est ici et dans nos
coeurs
[Applaudissements]
dernier jour de compétition aujourd'hui
sur cette ryder cup 2018 les supporters
sont en délire on saura aujourd'hui
qui remportera la coupe entre les
européens et les états unis pour
l'instant option pour les européens
[Musique]
oh
premier match de ce dernier jour de
compétition le nord irlandais rory
mcilroy a affronté justin thomass
l'américain dans une ambiance survoltée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est finalement l'europe qui
l'emportent
c'est tout simplement la folie sur des
chemins ceux de saint quentin en
yvelines
le dernier point a été emporté par
bolivar et 1 l'italien
c'est officiel les européens emporte
cette 42e ryder cup sur le score de 17
points et demi à 10 points et demi pour
les états unis et l'ambiance était
évidemment fantastique
[Musique]
et
ne te
m
[Musique]
une semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà on fût-ce à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial on
peut parler il s'en fout et demi bah oui
oui ça c'est c'est la fin d'une histoire
mais mais c'est merveilleux c'est la fin
de cette émission spéciale à ryder cup
rendez vous dans quatre ans en italie
pour une prochaine ryder cup sur le sol
européen
à bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
golfique
[Musique]